>> Jason: WELCOME BACK TO
THIS SPECIAL EDITION OF
"HANNITY."
"JUSTICE IF AMERICA."
NOW THE DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO
STOOP TO NEW LOWS SMEARING
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND ATTORNEY
GENERAL WILLIAM BARR.
RECKLESSLY CALLING FOR
IMPEACHMENT, AND EVEN JAIL
TIME, ALL WHILE FUELING CHAOS
ACROSS CAPITOL HILL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK IS
IMPORTANT IS TO RECOGNIZE 10
MILLION PEOPLE SAID THAT WE
NEED TO HOLD THIS PRESIDENT
ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT SPEAKS VOLUMES.
>> THE IMPEACHMENT PROCESS WAS
CREATED FOR SOMEONE LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> WE HAVE A DUTY,
RESPONSIBILITY AND THE
OBLIGATION UNDER THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA TO DO OUR
DUTY.
WE MUST IMPEACH.
LET THE SENATE DO WHAT THEY
MAY.
WE HAVE TO DO WHAT WE MUST.
>> NOW, I WILL SAY HAVING
OBSTRUCTED THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATION AND
NOW OBSTRUCTING CONGRESS, THE
CASE FOR IMPEACHMENT GAINS
WEIGHT.
>> TO ENSURE THAT WE GET THAT
REPORT BECAUSE WE HAVE LAWFUL
RESPONSIBILITIES,
CONSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES TO ENGAGE IN.
ONE OF WHICH IS POSSIBLY
IMPEACHMENT.
HOW CAN WE IMPEACH WITHOUT
GETTING THE DOCUMENTS?
>> Jason: LIKE CLOCKWORK,
THE MEDIA IS DOING THE
DEMOCRATS BIDDING ALONG THE
WAY.
HERE IS JUST A SMALL SAMPLE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU ARE DEFENDING THE MOST
CORRUPT ATTORNEY GENERAL.
I MEAN SINCE JOHN MITCHELL.
IT'S BAD.
YOUR ARTICLE IS GOING TO LOOK
EXEXTRAORDINARILY STUPID AND
YOU ARE GOING TO LOOK LIKE
WELL, A SYCOPHANT.
IT'S EMBARRASSING.
JOINING ME NOW FOR REACTION IS
FOX NEWS CON STRIBOR RACHEL
CAMPY DUFFY.
AND KAYLEIGH.
RACHEL, THE TOPIC HERE IS
"JUSTICE IN AMERICA."
MUELLER DOES A REPORT.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL PUTS IT
OUT WITH EVERYTHING EXCEPT
WHAT HE IS PROHIBITED BY LAW.
THEY WANT TO HOLD HIM IN
CONTEMPT.
THEY WANT HIM TO GO TO JAIL
ESSENTIALLY?
THEY MIGHT IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT?
IS THAT JUSTICE IN AMERICA?
>> IT'S NOT.
YOU KNOW, YOU HAD JOE
SCARBOROUGH SAYING THAT THE
REPUBLICANS LOOK INCREDIBLY
STUPID.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
LOOK NOT ONLY INCREDIBLY
STUPID, BUT INCREDIBLY CORRUPT
WHEN BARR GETS TO THE BOTTOM
OF HOW THIS INVESTIGATION
STARTED BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THE DOSSIER WAS DIRTY.
WE KNOW IT WAS USED TO SPY ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AND NOW WE ARE HEARING THAT
THE F.B.I. KNEW IT WAS DIRTY
BEFORE THEY GAVE IT TO THE
FISA JUDGES.
SO THIS IS VERY SERIOUS STUFF.
I THINK PART OF THIS IS NOT
JUST TO SULLY THE PRESIDENT
AND MAKE IT LOOK LIKE HE IS
HIDING SOMETHING BECAUSE THEY
ARE STILL CLINGING TO THIS
COLLUSION AND THE OBSTRUCTION
STUFF BUT ALSO TO SULLY BARR.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW SOMETHING IS
COMING OUT.
IT'S NOT JUST WHAT IS
HAPPENING AT THE F.B.I.
OR THE CORRUPTION OF THE
F.B.I.
THIS GOES ALL THE WAY TO THE
TOP.
THIS GOES ALL THE WAY TO
OBAMA, BIDEN, VALERIE JARRETT,
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE REALLY
WORRIED ABOUT.
>> Jason: I THINK YOU ARE
RIGHT.
I THINK THEY ARE SO WORRIED
ABOUT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
REPORT AND WHAT ATTORNEY
GENERAL BARR IS COMING WITH.
WE HAD ADAM SCHIFF, HE IS ON
THE COVER OF "NEWSWEEK" FOR
GOODNESS SAKE.
HE IS OUT THERE SAYING THAT IT
GAINED WEIGHT.
THE IDEA OF IMPEACHMENT GAINED
WEIGHT.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
HE SHOULDN'T EVEN HAVE A
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE HE'S EVEN IN
CONGRESS THE WAY HE TOLD THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR TWO YEARS
WHAT THE MUELLER REPORT WAS
GOING TO REPORT AND THEN IT
DIDN'T.
>> RIGHT.
THIS IS A GUY WHO SAID HE HAD
SAMPLE EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
WE HAVE YET TO SEE HIM HELD TO
ACCOUNT.
IT'S LAUGHABLE THE NOTION OF
IMPEACHMENT.
THE MONTAGE OF CLIPS YOU
PLAYED IS ALSO LAUGHABLE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING OH,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOADING
IMPEACHMENT.
WHAT AN ABSURD ASSERTION.
THE ONLY ONES GOADING
IMPEACHMENT ARE THE DEMOCRATS
YOU SAW SAY "IMPEACHMENT" OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
65% OPPOSE IMPEACHMENT SO THEY
ARE GOING DOWN THIS ROAD AND
THEY WILL DO SO AT THEIR OWN
DETRIMENT AS WE APPROACH THE
2020 ELECTION.
TRUMP HAS SO MANY RESULTS TO
SELL AND THEY ONLY HAVE
INVESTIGATIONS THAT ARE
MERITLESS.
>> Jason: EARLIER IN THE
SHOW TREY GOWDY SAID ONE OF
HIS DISAPPOINTMENTS IN EIGHT
YEARS IN CONGRESS IS THE WAY
THAT NATIONAL MEDIA TREATED
THE IMBALANCE.
THEY LOOKED AT THE REPUBLICANS
AND THEY TREATED THEM TOTALLY
DIFFERENT THAN DEMOCRATS.
RACHEL, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON
HOW THE NATIONAL MEDIA IS
COVERING THE STORY AND THE
REACTION OF HOW BARR HAS
HANDLED THIS MUELLER REPORT?
>> ABSOLUTELY PROOF THAT THE
MEDIA IS IN THE TANK WITH THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEIR BIAS IS ON DISPLAY.
KAYLEIGH HITS A GOOD POINT.
IF YOU THINK BACK TO THE
MIDTERMS, THAT WI NOT TALKING
ABOUT IM -- THEY WERE NOT
TALKING ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
THEY WERE FOCUSED ON THE
ISSUE.
THAT IS WHY THEY WON.
BUT NOW THEY'RE BACK TO
IMPEACHMENT.
THIS IS RISKY BECAUSE IT WILL
REV UP THEIR BASE BUT IT'S
ALSO REVVING UP AND ANGERING
UP THE REPUBLICAN BASE.
WHAT IS LEFT IS THE SWING
VOTERS.
THE SWING VOTERS IN THE STATES
LIKE PENNSYLVANIA AND
WISCONSIN AND OHIO.
PLACES WHERE THE PRESIDENT HAS
ABSOLUTELY DELIVERED ON JOBS.
ON THE ECONOMY.
WE'RE ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
WE'RE SO STRONG FINALLY AFTER
DECADES WE ARE TAKING ON
CHINA.
THE GIANT CHEATERS.
WE COULDN'T DO THAT IF WE
WEREN'T IN A STRONG ECONOMIC
POSITION WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS A TIME FOR THE COUNTRY
TO UNITE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THAT.
WE ARE STRONGER FIGHTING CHINA
ON THE TARIFFS WHEN WE ARE
UNITED.
AND THEY SEE THE DEMOCRATS
FOCUS ON THIS.
WHEN THE ELECTIONS COME ALONG,
THE SWING VOTERS WILL LOOK AT
THE DEMOCRATS AND SAY WHAT
HAVE THEY DONE FOR ME?
STUPID INVESTIGATIONS THAT
THEY SAID MUELLER WAS THE
FINAL WORD.
THE FINAL WORD COMES OUT AND
NOW THEY WILL KEEP GOING.
OR DONALD TRUMP WHO HAS
DELIVERED IN SPADES TO EVERY
PROMISE HE MADE.
>> Jason: KAYLEIGH
EMPEACHMENT AND CONTEMPT IS
THAT THE WINNING MESSAGE FOR
AMERICA?
REAL QUICK.
20 SECONDS LEFT.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I GO TO ALL THE PRESIDENT'S
RALLIES.
72% OF THE REGISTRANTS OF THE
EL PASO RALLY WERE DEMOCRATS
OR SWING VOTERS.
WHEN I TALK TO THEM IN LINE
THEY TALK ABOUT HEALTHCARE AND
THE ECONOMY.
THEY TALK ABOUT THE ISSUES.
IMPEACHMENT IS LAST ON THE